my body is smelly and tired that's a
great perfume name
hi guys screw somebody here if you did
not know now you know your life is
different now I am tired because I just
got back a few hours ago from New York
City I was there to attend the VMAs with
mamrie Hart which is appropriate for
this video that I'm doing right now the
red carpet fashion review of the VMAs
result if you don't follow me on
snapchat you should be following me real
grace Helbig is my name and if you were
following me then you saw that I saw
bounce they arrived at the VMAs and I
saw her perform and I don't know
anything that happened after that cuz I
just watch out oh I yell she did a
medley of lemonade and at the very end
of lemonade she did formation and let me
just take you through something that I
did in response to that it was exactly
this oh [ __ ] is that around strangers I
didn't know let's get into her comment
review
who's first it's Beyonce hey long time
no see I like this dress because it
looks like a fish with like a beard
around its mouth it's like in the
process of eating her whole and it just
has to finish wrapping around her head
you look fishy girl is that a compliment
I don't think it's a compliment that
might be a bad thing you a squishy girl
it's just so cool you just make
everything look cool you're cool you're
cool okay moving on ariana grande also
was amazing at the VMAs she rode a
bicycle wall singing and doing
choreography I'm over three on all that
entire scenario I kind of like what
you're wearing to me there's something
about this that screams like Paula Abdul
80s bangs and crimped hair like any
other girl you'd be like are you okay
what's happening but for you I'm like oh
oh okay what's happening I bet she's got
a sexy top on and then she was running
out the door and really shows already
pants and so she went
downtown New York City and found some
like finance banker was like give me
your pants
and he did kill Kim and Kanye this is a
look this is very wet steel to me I feel
like in this picture you guys are
actually just inside of a sauna
also there's a scrunching that's
happening in the front of the dress and
if you look really quickly the strings
look like they could be coming out of
your vagina looks like she's trying a
very experimental new line of fashion
tampons
I don't know cute Naomi Campbell yes
this looks nice you don't age what's
that like this is a strapless velvet
mini dress in teal what this also looks
very 80s to me it also looks like you
took a car seat and put it on yourself a
little bit you he did he I located it
looked great I feel like beat it he
hasn't changed his look in like 15 years
except he decided to add a kimono on top
I also like that he did not follow that
rule about take off an accessory before
you leave the house no in fact he
reversed it he flipped it and reversed
it if I provide a brush for you you know
that's on music everyone's doing it
Britney Spears I thought she looked
great on the red carpet it looks like
she could have been during that day
wearing a dress that like a high-powered
executive lawyer lady would wear
initially I'm gonna VMAs Shh let's go Q
ah the gymnasts it's the final five
except Gabby Davis wasn't there if you
follow me on instagram hey wendy one of
those extra outlet strips because i got
two plugs in this video already if you
follow my instagram you saw in memory
and I met these lovely wonderful happy
ladies and they were so sweet but it was
more like we asked to take a photo with
them and they looked at us very scared
because we're with our heels probably
like six to each and so very
intimidating but they took the phone
with us so sweetly and they just walked
away kind of looking confused at it I
think they're trying to figure
like who we were and like if we were
gonna fall over on them because we
weren't the steadiest in heels Alicia
Keys is Swizz Beatz Alicia Keys came to
the VMAs without wearing any makeup and
I couldn't even tell because she just
looks pretty and like she is wearing
makeup I like the dress I like her the
whole thing's cool you guys look cool
you look like you know that you're cool
and then you don't you don't need this
validation not even being cool because
you just you know we're different so so
different Michael Phelps and his wife
miss beautiful woman they look great you
guys look clean and nice and like
high-end is a phrase that comes to mind
you guys look like you don't need
funfetti cake good for you
Nicki Minaj why do you push ups you I
even look so sad so many photos I have a
view to view on my carpets just look so
sad ariana grande came with bangs creme
care and some stockbrokers pants on and
I'm looking at you like are you sad damn
that buddy is a buddy you look like an a
doll like you look like you were built
in a lab a lab run my scientists at like
sad sexy women gez the self it does not
seem easy
you got a belly button sound that riddle
assault thanks to that you have a girl
or no cowboy pirate the thing is I don't
just like this outfit it's a music award
show and you do music so you're doing it
Nick Jonas look at you being Nick Jonas
you're wearing a jacket that I would
wear
in fact you're an entire outfit that I
would wear in fact are we the same
person Rita Ora there's a lot going on
here you look like a lamp at a cabaret
bar and I like it
Jojo you look like a rug a good rug a
very sexy 70s rug that someone recycled
but cool but you're doing it with the
butt Jaden Smith hi friend
are you okay are you sad do you feel
anything you know I like this everyone
makes fun of you all the time because
you're different than them
you got weird style like
predict and I kind of like that about
you that no one really knows what's
gonna happen but it's never offensive
it's just like makes me a little anxious
by association like I feel like you're
probably hot make sure you hydrate Ansel
Elgort
Alcor Ansel Elgort for eggs warts this
is a look I appreciate you try something
different
tell that Korey Kuhl tweeted a-- you had
a very advert scissors hand look that
you were serving and i agree with it it
kinda looks like you're wearing pants
that you made using all the parts on the
inside of your computer very DIY this is
very hot topic meets all of my older
brothers south jersey sky loving friends
from high school thank you for giving me
this little bit of nostalgia this it's
good this is a band why does this give
me anxiety why does it look like they're
all done like this this is cool you guys
are very much a band i see that visually
you're really letting us know that
you're a band and it looks like you're a
band and congrats you won for best new
artist so you know story checks out s it
looks a little bit like a cam peel
sketch right now our imitates life that
man with the necklaces had to wake up
with such pain the next day also he's
got three flies tripled the risk of you
having your fly down you guys are risk
takers sep for you crank your singer
that somehow got it has been fit Armony
damn i played the fifth because you guys
are so good I might say something that's
illegal what you guys just look really
really good yours are all showing off
different body parts that I feel like if
we took all those pieces together we'd
have one naked person so cute
kudos ever owes kind of looks like the
sexy banker wife of the stock broker
that ariana grande stole the pants of
came to the award show to get his pants
back but she forgot her shirt on the way
out halsy I don't even know this was her
is she wearing she's wearing a wig piece
of hair fake hair this looks great
you look like sexy sir
this Acrobat slash ice dancer slash goth
version of Elsa from frozen all mixed
into one and that's really cute music
like your look has a lot of layers
Frankie grande what a guy this is great
and he's on theme he's not wearing a
shirt he got glitter everywhere and he's
just got the best energy ever I think my
new favorite TV show is watching Frankie
watch award shows cuz he just loves them
so hard and he just lives a thousand
lives every time I liked it there my
thoughts on the VMA white carpet
let me know what you guys thought and
also subscribe to the channel if you
like this video or if you just like wish
that you could get these minutes back in
your life pick that button right there
and we'll be here forever until we're I
don't know who let these puppets in